uh thank you very much my name is adrian
dix nbc's minister of health in victoria
is dr bonnie henry vc's provincial
health officer i'm honored to be here on
the territories of the mosque queen of
the squamish of the slave tooth people
honored to be here on their lands dr
henry is
on the territory of the luang and
speaking people the sangees
and the esquimalt first nations today uh
here to provide you an update on the
coven 19 pandemic in british columbia to
answer your questions and with that it's
my honor to introduce dr bonnie henry
on the current orders that we have in
place
some of which are due to expire
first i would like to apologize for the
confusion on the order timing and the
adjustments that were
required yesterday the intent was to
have the orders in place until i could
provide clear direction on on orders
onto at today's briefing and i know that
was
a little bit of an error on our part
about
having them expire at 1201 versus 11 59
tonight
as we know we put these orders in place
in december december 21st and 24th when
we saw the wave of omicron coming at us
and we still
did not know a lot of the pieces of the
puzzle about what this was going to look
like we took measures early because we
have learned through these waves of this
pandemic that waiting means that our
systems can become overwhelmed very very
quickly and particularly when we were
seeing how rapidly
this virus and this strain of the virus
was transmitting
given the current rates of transmission
and what we saw from the presentations
that i gave on friday for example and
the number of people currently requiring
hair care in hospital
which is at the highest level for covid
cases that we have had
i will be extending the current
restrictions on events and gatherings
through to february 16th
at which point we will reassess the need
once again
to keep any or all of these measures in
place so this will
apply to the the closures that we have
right now in bars and nightclubs
limitations that we have in restaurants
to make sure that we're minimizing the
risk of
transmission in those settings and the
capacity limits the 50 percent capacity
limits in theaters and stadiums etc
in addition uh the covid safety plan
order remains in place and it is an
important tool for workplaces to use and
i would like to remind all businesses
that this is something that will help us
to continue to function and to function
through this next few weeks as well
we know
and additionally there will be no
changes to the vaccine card the bc
vaccine card orders that are in place we
know that this is a very important and
effective tool that helps make sure
we're minimizing and mitigating risks in
those many settings
where the vaccine card is in play
i know that many people felt that we
were overreacting and i've said this
from the very beginning of the pandemic
that our challenge and my challenge is
to find that balance of making sure
we're doing just enough to address the
situations we're in and not
not allowing our system to be
overwhelmed to focus on minimizing the
risk of serious illness hospitalization
but also minimizing the societal impacts
as well and we've had to adjust and we
had to adjust in
december once again as the virus changed
it changed and we needed to change with
it
but that is why after looking at the
data that we have and presenting that as
we did on friday today i'm taking the
cautious step of reopening gyms and
exercise facilities with capacity limits
and the continued use of the bc vaccine
card
the the
these new guidelines have new guidelines
have been developed and we've been
working very closely
with the
fitness industry council of canada and i
can't say enough about how
responsive they have been to the needs
of the fitness industry and the gyms as
also
looking at the data that we have in
working with us to put together new
guidelines and these will be in effect
with the restart of gyms starting on
on january 20th and that will include
individual and group fitness
being able to resume at fitness centers
and gyms across the province proof of
vaccine will continue of course to be
required at all locations
and we have
limits that include a minimum of seven
meters square for every individual for
exercise in in and that's about a 2.5 by
2.5 meters and much of this is based on
what we learned when we had our phased
restart of gyms and and fitness centers
in
in 2020 and 2021 so we've learned about
the measures that are important to help
make sure that they can restart safely
and still protect people who are most at
risk
the spacing requirements applies to
people working out on their own
whether it's doing weights or on a
treadmill but also applies to to group
fitness classes to have that
unencumbered space around people
there must be enhanced ventilation with
no fans or heaters to increase the
temperature of the space making sure
that we have that
important measure to to ensure re
reduction in in virus loads if possible
looking at pre-bookings and time between
classes as as those are operationally
possible and of course continuing with
things like cleaning in addition mass
must be worn at all times
except when exercising as we know that
that can cause
challenges for some people however i
will say it is absolutely encouraged
during exercise depending on what you're
doing for most people given what we know
about transmission with omicron right
now and must be used at all times by
instructors and personal trainers and
staff
i think this is a really important
measure i really want to thank
particularly the owners and operators
and staff who've worked in gyms around
the province and who recognized that
this was another change and very
challenging situation with the spread of
omicon
and they did what we asked to protect
their workers and their gym community
and i am very grateful that they've
taken these measures i know and please
know it was a very difficult decision
to close gyms and
and fitness facilities before the
holidays
but it did give us that time to make
that assessment particularly looking at
people who were using these
settings and making sure we had
additional measures in place that would
address what we were seeing and again i
just want to um say my my profound
thanks to the fitness industry council
of canada's particularly sarah hodgson
and carl omer who
have been working with us all along
through this pandemic but we're really
instrumental in having us develop these
safe guidelines
for reopening this week
in addition to
this order
i am also i've also put in a new order
which came up yesterday which enabled
medical health officers across the
province
to support school districts in
in looking at staff vaccination rates
this was put in place to support the
mhos who are working with their school
districts across the province to make
those important decisions around the
need for vaccine mandates the first step
in this and this is part of the advice
that we've been providing to school
districts is understanding the
vaccination status of school staff
and we know that several school
districts had challenges in obtaining
this important information and the mhos
have been working with a number of
districts over the last the last few
months and concerns were expressed from
unions and others about the legality of
of obtaining this information
so this is to make it very clear uh this
also this decision this order also
assists mhos in knowing which schools
are most at risk of outbreaks and it's a
way of us being able to prioritize and
manage and support schools
this order takes that pressure away and
makes it very clear that there is a
legal basis for this requirement and a
standard process for the mhos when
they're working with their school
districts to address these issues
so this has been in the works and has
been consulted on quite widely over
several
months and i know in interior health
in delta this is an important measure to
facilitate what school districts are
doing in making their decision around
their employees and vaccine mandates
as the data i shared on friday clearly
shows
there are a few groups of people who are
getting more seriously ill than others
as we're moving through this omicron
wave
primarily is people who don't have the
protection that vaccine offers at even
at younger ages
very clearly have an increased risk but
the second group of people that we're
also seeing are people that
are over age 70 we know that age remains
the single most important risk factor
for having severe illness with covid19
and omicron is no different so
regardless of vaccine status even with
two doses on board
we know that people over age 70 have
increased risk partly this is because of
our immune system not being as
responsive as we get older many older
people also have other underlying
conditions that put them at risk and the
other group that we are seeing who are
also still at risk now are people who
have underlying immune compromising
conditions so we need to really pay
attention i think there's a narrative
around right now that that omicron is
mild and many of us have experiences we
know people who've become sick with it
they've recovered we've known people as
well who have
had more serious illness and so we need
to be very careful to dismiss this right
now
it may be
most people are not becoming seriously
ill and ending up in hospital but with
the high rates of transmission there are
still lots of people who do get
seriously ill and even those people who
aren't in hospital this is not an
innocuous illness
the data has shown that up until now and
even with omicron about 1 in 10
people will have symptoms that last for
12 weeks or longer that's a long time to
be seriously ill
and while this new wave our individual
risk may have decreased for many
particularly if you're younger healthy
and and vaccinated omicron can and is
still causing serious illness in many
we may not end up in hospital but it can
lead to
many people being infected
leads to a strain on our hospitals at
the same time as we're also seeing
health care workers
becoming ill with this strain
it's still a serious issue and we are
still in a pandemic as much as we would
like to be over it
the one thing i will say and this is
born out again and again vaccines are
still the single most effective tool
that we have that will get us through
this wave but also for future waves so i
encourage everybody who's eligible
whether you're 5 or 55 or 95
get your vaccines
the first dose and second dose are
highly protective in the short term
against infection but in the long term
from serious infection from
hospitalization and that booster dose
boosts up that prevention of infection
so it does make a difference
now and in the future
it is our still our safest and most
effective tool
having said that we all know somebody
who's still at risk people who are over
age 70 people who have immune
compromising conditions going through
cancer treatments
and we all have these people in our
families in our social circles at work
we may not even know it so it remains
our collective responsibility to pay
attention to doing those things that
help prevent us from transmitting the
virus to others things that work and
that's what we know will get us through
this phase and get us through this
whatever this pandemic throws at us next
in terms of
workplaces as well
you know this is an important process we
talked about the coveted safety plans i
also want to emphasize that should
employees be ill and take sick days they
do not require a note from a physician
to get back to work or school or daycare
or child care
we also right now
there's no need if somebody has a
positive antigen test there's no need
for a pcr test to confirm that we know
uh with the rates of transmission we're
seeing in our communities and
the
this specificity and the sensitivity of
the rapid antigen test that if it's
positive
then you need to take action to prevent
transmission you don't require a
negative test to return to work
yesterday health canada approved the use
of
another tool that will help us in our
tool kit and that's paxlovid an oral
treatment that helps prevent more
serious illness if it's given to people
early on
this is canada's first oral antiviral
treatment for mild to moderate covet 19
and it's specifically for those
individuals at highest risk of more
severe developing more severe illness
and ending up in hospital
so again it includes those people in our
community who are older over age 70
clinically extremely vulnerable immune
compromised and for younger people who
have additional medical conditions and
don't have the protection of vaccines
for now though we will be receiving a
very limited supply we expect that in
the next few weeks or so we'll get about
4 000 treatment courses
and these must be started within five
days of symptom onset and that's how
they were used in the trials so we are
working with our clinical care advisory
team to distribute the treatment where
it can be most effective this is very
good news it's not going to change the
trajectory of our pandemic right now but
it is something that we have another
tool to help those people who do get
sick who are more risk at ending up in
hospital
i also want to say
that there are two additional vaccines
that continue to be under review by
health canada one of them is medicago
it's a
protein subunit vaccine that's made in
tobacco plants and the other is novovax
which has also had some very promising
both of which have had very promising
clinical trials
both of these are have been under review
they've been
novavax has been approved for use in a
few other countries around the world but
has had challenges in terms of scaling
up
we don't expect that it will be approved
for use or available in canada we're
hoping it would be uh sometime in
january but it looks like it's more
likely to be in february
metacargo maybe
the as early as
the end of january or february so i
think that's important for those people
who have
made that determination that the mrna
vaccines that we have and are holding
out for something else
it's not going to be available to help
you through this wave but it is an
additional option that will be coming we
hope
in the near future
finally i want to speak for a moment
about some of the misinformation that is
spreading out there particularly about
vaccines and especially in the changing
environment that we have right now
credible scientific sources for
information are vital to making those
important decisions for yourself and
your family about your health
so i strongly encourage people to not
pay attention to many of the things that
are spreading on social media
and in facebook and some of these posts
you need to find accurate credible
sources of information
and that of course starts with your
family practitioner with your
with your pediatrician with your
pharmacist and also the bc cdc website
which has additional information that we
put up there all the time about the
vaccines about vaccine safety about
questions that people may have
but also science-based sites such as
science up first these are places you
can go to help understand where some of
these kernels of information that get
twisted around happen
there's excellent information on all
sorts of topics that are top of the mind
for many one of the most important ones
right now is having that confidence to
get children five to 11 protected from
this virus we're seeing it affecting
younger children right now and it's
important
that we protect them from this infection
it's also
lots of information on the booster dose
and how well it works on protecting both
infection but again longer lasting
protection from serious illness
and i want to say as well that i am very
grateful for the many journalists who've
been covering covet 19 for the last two
years who've worked hard to make sure
that what they are presenting is
accurate and based on the factual
science
we learn information every day and when
things change it can sometimes lead us
to believe that we've been wrong about
things but really it's about adapting
and understanding as we go so there's a
few things that are really i can say
unequivocally vaccines do not change
your dna
vaccines do not affect fertility now or
in the future
vaccines do
protect you from infection and from
serious illness and we know that they
are very very safe yes
every vaccine every medication we have
does have the potential for side effects
but those are very very low even though
we've been monitoring these incredibly
um carefully over the last few
two years well year and a bit since the
vaccines have been available
i know there's a lot of concern about
the very rare side effect of vaccines
that causes inflammation of the heart or
the heart muscle or the whining of the
heart and again we have seen that that
can happen but it's extremely rare
post-vaccination what we have also seen
it is much much more common to have that
type of inflammatory response in the
heart muscles in the blood vessels after
infection with covid even with milder
infections and we've seen that in in
athletes and others around the world
including more recently alfonso davies
so i would encourage people please find
those credible informations that answers
your questions particularly about
vaccines because as we are seeing time
and time again they are an important way
to get us through this pandemic and to
keep people out of the hospital
i think
i will
leave it at that for today and turn it
over to minister dix
thank you very much dr henry and
i wanted to
provide some updates today on
vaccination on surgical postponements
the impacts of sickness on healthcare
workers and on the health care system
overall as well as the mitigation plans
in place to ensure british columbians
continue to receive the health care they
need and deserve
in addition i'll be updating on rapid
tests that are available in bc and
distributed across the province with
respect to immunization i note that 4
million 458
921 british columbians have received
their first dose of a coveted 19 vaccine
four million one hundred and fifty seven
thousand one hundred fifty their second
dose
and impressively one million five
hundred ninety one thousand five hundred
and six have received their third or
booster dose that over the last week a
very significant 383
266 vaccines have been administered in
bc which is an extraordinary achievement
including 351 000 and 571
third or booster doses that of all out
those eligible in the total population
uh um
for a feroci 19 vaccine 37 percent of
adults over 18 have received their
booster dose and of course a
significantly large percentage of those
who are actually eligible who have
already received
their second dose this is the work of
our teams and our vaccine teams across
british columbia has been exceptional i
want to note that 122 000 of those doses
have been in community pharmacy and to
thank with our healthcare teams and all
those working community pharmacy for
really what is an exceptional
achievement with respect to rapid tests
to date vc has received 4 million 859
800 rapid tests and deployed three
million four hundred and eighty three
thousand and fourteen of these tests to
key strategic areas
uh 563 000 of the current inventory are
not suitable for deployment for take
away or personal use they require
special equipment administration by
trained healthcare professionals and
cannot be broken down or repackaged
these tests will continue to be used at
the discretion of medical health
officers
that leaves eight hundred and thirteen
thousand seven hundred and eighty six
tests that are suitable for
self-administered use
this week's deliveries and allocations
will include an additional 150 000 to
replenish supplied acute healthcare
facilities for testing of symptomatic
healthcare workers an additional 96 200
for repackaging and distributing to
testing sites across bc 115 000 more
tests for a total of approximately three
hundred thousand are being prepared and
delivered to support testing in the k-12
education sector over two hundred
thousand will be deployed for use by
businesses and organizations as a part
of the point-of-care screening program
long-term care and assisted living sites
will continue to receive additional
inventory to replenish their supply
consistent with our previous plans
we expect of course more and more rapid
tests in the next couple of weeks and we
will continue to report on this and act
on this consistent with the plan we
outlined in detail on december 21st
2021.
uh with that i'd like to talk a little
bit about the impact on our healthcare
system where we are with respect to our
health care system
as noted we have we'll have today i
think in a hospital about 854 people
covered 19
positive cases in hospital and
approximately 112 in critical care
that's the number of those cases
the total number of people in hospital
is of course an important number that we
monitor
all the time and that number is
in terms of our base bed capacity which
is 929
we have on our base bed capacity
8778 in patients in bc hospitals that's
an occupancy rate of 95.1 percent
typically it's more than 100 percent
this time of year should be said
that we also have two thousand five
hundred and fifty
two hundred thousand three hundred fifty
three surge beds five hundred and seven
of seventy of those are occupied for a
total of twenty four point two percent
so our our total occupancy
uh across uh bc hospitals is nine
thousand three hundred and forty eight
on a base bed of nine two two eight and
a s and a base and surge bed of uh of
course about eleven thousand five
hundred
and eighty two so that's where we are in
terms of our hospitals right now
obviously
with respect to the impact of the
omicron variant of concern in kovan 19
as well as other sicknesses on our
health care workers and health care
system i want to report as follows our
healthcare workers have been performing
exceptionally well working very hard
under enormous pressure to get us
through this pandemic to address the
public health emergency that is the
overdose public health emergency and to
provide all the other services that are
needed particularly in a time of the
year january when we typically see
significant demand for health care i am
unceasingly thankful for their
determination endurance and skill
with the appropriate public health
orders in place to slow the transmission
of covet 19
we know still that omicron is highly
transmissible and infecting more british
colombians than ever before and while
vaccination remains the best defense
it's imperative that people follow
public health orders wear a mask and
stay home when sick or symptomatic
health authorities have been closely
monitoring sickness levels across health
services especially in hospitals
long-term care and home support
i can report that from january 10th to
16th 2022 across the province and across
all sectors 17 5 958 health care workers
called in sick due to cloven 19 yes and
other illnesses that's all illnesses
combined this is the total number of
health care workers who called in sick
at any point during the week and does
not reflect the number of days they may
have called in sick
this includes total includes 2973
in vancouver coastal health
3069 in interior health
3317 in island health 827
in providence healthcare
1459 in northern health
and 44 health and
1873 in the provincial health services
authority and the bc emergency health
services
combined just to put that in context
that is less than the number of people
who called in sick the previous week
january 3rd to 9th that number which has
been updated is
19976 so that number has gone from
1976 to 17
958 to provide some further context
because there was interest in the part
of the media in the health authorities
where we have comparators back to 2020.
i can report that january 10th to 16
2022 approximately the number was eleven
thousand five hundred and seventy two in
those health authorities that's minus
v-haw
vancouver island health and interior
health the number we called in sick last
year was seven thousand five hundred and
seventy three and the number in the
previous year was just over eight
thousand those previous years were for
january third to ninth but that provides
some context so it's significantly more
although the gap is less than it was uh
last week uh and uh and so just to again
to put that in context certainly that
puts significant pressure on our health
care system and we're responding to that
through a number of measures to address
and and ensure that core services are in
place and people get the health care
they need when they need it so with that
one critical element of that is of
course the surgical renewal update and
the surgic and the impact on surgery so
here's the report for this week health
authorities report 4 322 surgeries were
completed from december 19 to december
25th this is 2198 more surgeries in the
same week pre-pandemic it should be said
that that week in 2019 included both the
christmas and boxing day holiday so it's
not apples to apples but it is more than
then from january 9th to 15th more
recent period health authorities
postponed 791 non-urgent scheduled
surgeries that's 42 in fraser health 119
in vancouver coastal health 240 in
interior health
355 in island health
and 35 in the provincial health services
authority no surgeries were postponed in
the northern health authority and so
just to put that in context in that week
791 non-urgent scheduled surgeries
postponed that number in the weeks of
course around april and may 2020 was
more than 3 000 so it is not the same
level of cancellation as it was or of
postponement as it was then nonetheless
it is obviously significant particularly
for those whose surgeries have been
postponed to say the least cumulatively
from september 5th to january 15th there
have been 5 101 surgical post moments
due to regional surges of covet and
factors including severe weather
patterns
in kovid's first wave as you'll remember
march to may 2020 of the 14 842 patients
who wish to proceed with their postponed
surgeries 99.6 percent have now had
their surgeries with guidance from the
ministry health authorities have devised
temporary mitigation plans as well to
maintain safe patient care and the the
the the already discussed postponement
of some non-urgent scheduled surgeries
is part of that it remains our priority
to sustain essential health care
services throughout every region of the
province where we work together to
overcome coven 19. of course our goal is
to have our healthcare system operating
at 100
everywhere in every facet as soon as
possible as we've demonstrated with
surgeries in the past it's our intention
to do so
in the meantime service changes will
vary by health authority and community
depending on the present needs and
challenges and will be monitored and
adjusted accordingly health authorities
will be providing information bulletins
at around three o'clock today to
describe what is going on in their
health authorities in more detail than i
am providing here
in vancouver coastal and fraser health
sustaining full staffing continues of
course to be a challenge across those
regions and makes it difficult to
maintain the highest level of care
services in some rural communities
surgical capacity and specialized
programs
those two health authorities maintain
business continuity plans and
continually monitor evaluate and respond
to staffing challenges over the past
month temporary measures have been
adopted to address immediate
requirements as needed this is included
as you'll note from previous uh
rescheduling non-urgent
surgeries
fraser health has seen a small number of
home support visits rescheduled due to
staffing challenges the situation is
monitored daily and changes made as
needed to minimize service disruptions
interior health is taking is facing in
some ways the most significant
challenges not just because of
significant covet 19 race because of the
incredible challenges that the health
authority has faced
over the last number of months including
as everyone knows the heat dome
firefighter wildfires and floods and
other conditions
they are temporarily post-closing
in-patient services in clear water in
vemer and lillowite to stabilize the
emergency departments in those
communities they're reducing overnight
hours at ashcroft in the slokan health
center to again stabilize daytime time
services in those communities the
barrier and district health center will
be closed to redeploy staff to nearby
emergency departments all non-urgent
scheduled surgeries are being
rescheduled as noted before and
temporary reductions are being
implemented at outpatient clinics and
allied health services
in ireland health again elective
scheduled surgeries were postponed in a
majority of hospitals in early january
and will continue to be postponed until
the end of the month at the three
largest sites which is nanaimo the vic
general and royal jubilee hospital raw
remaining sites begin restarting or
staffing level support
a number of ambulatory care services
have been slowed down with services
maintained for those in greatest need
and there's other details around
slowdowns across island health that will
be available in their
information bullet
staffing levels are being adjusted on a
day-to-day and shift-to-shift basis and
in advance wherever possible to balance
risk and help utilize human resources
most efficiently across the system
in northern health surgical service
postponements are planned or ongoing in
the coming weeks the university hospital
northern dc by rich memorial hospital in
hazelton bulkley valley district
hospital in smithers and in northwest bc
facilities including the dawson creek
and district hospital impacting both
surgical and ambulatory care procedures
as was described happen before christmas
several
in long-term care staffing at sites
across the region is being monitored on
a daily basis and there are temporary
reductions across northern health
regions to adult day programs and
non-urgent home health services
temporary reductions are being
implemented across northern health in
some of these areas including laboratory
services in some communities and finally
situation response teams are in place to
support site managers in hazelton and
burns lake as both communities are
experiencing staffing challenges across
all facilities and services in the
provincial health service authority a
series of temporary adjustments are
being implemented and staff are working
diligently to ensure patients and
clients
continue to get a high level of service
and this describes in phsa what's
happening in all health authorities
which they've activated a variety of
strategies to mitigate the impact of
increased sick time some of these
strategies include leveraging overtime
for staff and redeploying staff to
different programs and services based on
areas of highest need centralizing
administrative services and deploying
administrative staff to reduce staffing
demands and where appropriate using
virtual health technology to expand
capacity there'll be more information in
their bulletin bc emergency health
services is experiencing some delays
with repatriation of patients by air
transport notably returning patients
from metro vancouver hospitals to their
home health authorities delays have
occurred to it due to a variety of
reasons including overall air ambulance
volumes and poor weather
all cases are triaged according to
acuity with first priority always being
for patients with the most urgent care
needs
all of these measures are designed to
stabilize our health care system while
we continue to battle covet 19 in the
omnicron variant of concern
and i understand some of these measures
may cause concerns and challenges for
patients and we are determined to get
services up and back and running in full
as soon as possible we have seen the
growth in cases and hospitalizations due
to the omertarian of concern but mostly
and differently in this
in this period in this wave of cases the
omicron wave of cases a significant
effect on all of our health care systems
on our healthcare workers and you see
that in the numbers of people who are
off sick
i think in this moment of the pandemic a
time that is of greatest challenge for
patients waiting for their surgeries our
job all of our job remains constant and
we must perform it with the same
dedication and drive we did almost two
years ago through our first postponement
it's this moment that matters and the
difference each of us makes in us
follow all public health guidance
consistently rely on our coveted sense
constantly book our vaccinations and
boosters when invited immediately and
protect our children with their
pediatric vaccinations
diligently and with that we're happy to
take your questions
we'll be limited to one question and one
follow-up first question today goes to
lisa cordasco vancouver's son
thank you very much good afternoon um
island health has reacted to a shortage
of rapid tests in its long-term care
facilities by asking its operators to
review their current supply of rapid
tests
with the recommendation that operators
priori prioritize their current supply
of rapid tests to ensure that you know
they're able to accommodate all
essential visitors until further supply
and timing of delivery delivery is
confirmed um can you explain why this
has occurred and how widespread this
shortage of
rapid antigen tests are in long-term
care homes in bc and can confirm the
supply and timing of the delivery of
rapid tests to long-term care homes
so perhaps i'll start and then i'll turn
it over to the minister to talk about
some of the supply issues but yes
they
what we want to do in long-term care is
ensure that we are safely allowing those
important essential and
important visitors in to support
residents in long-term care so
prioritizing making sure that we have
the ability to test people and to to
look at triaging who you need to to test
with the rapid tests if they are in
short supply we also know that many more
tests are coming in and they're being
forwarded to long-term care homes even
as we speak so
this is a time limited issue
that is happening in places across the
province but as more and more of the
rapid tests are available and we're able
to deploy them um it will become less
and less of an issue and it's an
incredibly important thing i've said
many times how we do know it is
essential that
people are able to visit their loved one
in in long-term care and we have a
process for
a designated visitor for every resident
over to minister dicks
just to say we are receiving a very
substantial supply long term just to say
we are receiving a very substantial
supply from care is
the highest priority in that supply and
uh and the resources are being
distributed if there are short-term
concerns so i'm happy to look into that
lisa but i think
those supplies are going to be in place
they're coming in from canada and we're
expecting a number this week and
continuing to be distributed so
it's a high priority for us and uh i
expect those rapid tests will be
distributed whether there may be a
an interim supply problem it's good to
know i guess what everyone has but i
think
this the supply issue
should largely be resolved soon
pcr tests
can you explain why bc has not reached
its 20 000 test per day uh capacity
except for one day in december um and
that's january 16th like there were
about 10 000 tests done uh you know at
the same time people are waiting hours
in line and some you know not being able
to get a pcr test at all so what's
happening with that
yeah it has a lot to do with titrating
uh demand and access and so we have been
using as we as we've mentioned a number
of times supplementing those who
who are at lower risk with the rapid
tests and those being distributed to
people at the testing centers and making
sure we have the pcr ability for those
who wear a pcr test is required
for access to treatment and for other
issues so it is
really prioritizing where we're using
that scarce resource and
not going up to 20 000 a day does give
our lab the ability to process faster so
it is finding that that right balance of
who needs a test
and with uh i mentioned this a little
bit about people returning to work and
and the rapid antigen tests in somebody
with symptoms right now with the level
that we have transmitting if it is a
positive test then it uh
it's it suffices for people um who
aren't at higher risk of ending up in
hospitals so we are titrating the use of
the pcr tests we don't have to use
everyone every day
we want to make sure that they're
available for
those people who need them
next question we go to richard sussman
global news
dr henry
part of the decision today made on gyms
was it based on uh public pressure and
concerns from a lot of gym users that it
was a crucial part of their mental
health and can you explain specifically
around the science why
it is safer now to enter a gym with
record-breaking hospitalizations than it
is uh to go to a venue with more than 50
capacity
yeah so
no it wasn't a public pressure so much
we worked really closely with
the gym industry as i said uh we've had
representatives that have been part of
our team understanding this for a long
time and
they
brought the issues with us and walked
through them
really when we looked at
you know i talked about this a little
bit on friday the various different
things that we look at when we put in
place restrictions and obviously
we consider these really carefully i
know how important it is to have
physical exercise for our mental health
or emotional health for people who are
in recovery from different injuries etc
and
the gym is part of that for many many
people
yoga studios fitness studios those are
all part of how people
express their their need for for
wellness as well as
for physical activity and i know that
too
i am also one of those people that uses
it my gym but i will say that when we're
at that place we look at the highest
risk scenarios so there are things that
we do
there's a population that we have
there's a setting
there's the the prior history of
outbreaks that we've seen and there's
transmission and with the demographic
that we know that are going to gyms on a
regular basis we were seeing a lot of
transmission in that age group in
december
when we
needed to look at what restrictions
needed to make a difference and so when
somebody is exercising vigorously you
expel more droplets we know that that's
a higher risk activity particularly if
it's indoors particularly if there's
limited space and we know that there was
we had been at a a really good point
where we were allowed we relaxed the
amount of space that was needed for each
individual in gyms so we had to adjust
because the virus changed and we were
seeing it move very rapidly through
populations and you saw the trajectory
of age groups that it was moving through
over the past month so that was the
basis for the decision and yes it's it's
qualitatively quite different from
sitting in a movie theater with a mask
on
so that is why we took the measures that
we did in those settings so seated
venues are very different from some
place where you're either actively
yelling or shouting or dancing or
singing
so a seated venue where mask wearing is
in force where you have space around you
we
mitigated the risk in those settings by
making the capacity 50
so that allows for more space around
individuals given what we didn't know
yet about omicron so yes what we've seen
is this has moved through in the
sort of in the community setting and we
know now that people who are vaccinated
with their two doses and now that age
group is all eligible for booster doses
as well in the younger age groups that
this is very protective particularly for
severe illness so we can safely restart
with some more capacity limits some of
those higher risk settings like our gyms
and fitness facilities
starting this week
given that we know that it is people who
are vaccinated
that this is an important part of
maintaining our overall overall health
and wellness and i think kudos to the
the fitness and gym communities who've
really done a great job at at
recognizing and supporting us when
this was a challenging time and i know
it's been a very challenging time for
them and i know
that i'm we're all very happy that we
can safely get back to going to our our
local gym now again
richard do you have a follow-up
doctor henry there continues to be a lot
of parents told
that they can't attend
their daycare
if their child was a close contact
to a covet positive person
for
in some cases 14 10 or 14 days last week
you indicated that kids could go back to
daycare or school uh when they're not
symptomatic so can you explain where the
breakdown is will there be an update it
provided on the bc cdc website because a
lot of the operators are just basing
their information on that and you know
should families be required to pay for
child care
at the facility when they're told they
can't attend due to a close contact or
in some cases because the facility is
not operating
because the operators are sick
yeah so in terms of you know should
people have to pay those are not
questions that i can answer i know that
is all in
the
the realm of of the the management of
the facilities but what i can say is
that yes you know through this whole
time we have been in through the last
two years
early childhood educators child care
workers have done an amazing job at
really
managing to care for children safely
especially the youngest children who
can't be immunized and still can't and
who can't
necessarily wear masks very effectively
either and i really want to stay
share my my gratitude for
the sector who's done an amazing job and
it has been a challenge as we have
changed and we've had to change to to
deal with the challenging and different
situation that omicron is presenting us
so yes those are still the guidelines
that were in place as things have
transitioned
there's been
challenges in some places in taking up
the new protocols we've been working
with the sector very actively over the
last couple of weeks as we've updated
our understanding about what it means
right now as the testing strategies have
changed and as we've understood that
more and more people particularly who
are vaccinated are having milder illness
and shorter illnesses so it is a time of
transition right now
we are working with mcfd and with the
child care sector and early childhood
educators we've been updating the
guidance in partnership with
them and this will be coming out in the
uh i know we have a
a town hall with uh
and
and
childhood
child care operators in the next coming
days and we'll be working through these
scenarios with them so this will settle
down it is a time of transition and
change
in many different areas as we've learned
more about really the impact that
omicron is having in our community so
yes
you don't need to and that is a change
you don't need to isolate if you've been
a contact and you're a healthy child and
we need to help walk people through what
that's going to look like in the coming
days
next question bender sagin ctv
oh hi dr henry i'm just wondering uh
first of all you can just confirm that
sports tournaments weddings funerals
gatherings all of that
remains as it is now and secondly just
wanted to ask you uh with regards to
this vaccination data for school staff
can you explain why it's important to
have that order in place and how that
information potentially uh could be used
yeah so uh in terms of
just to
to make it clear we have never uh had a
prohibitions or
not allowed weddings or funerals it's
the celebrations of life or the wedding
receptions and parties afterwards that
have been
suspended for now so the wedding itself
is absolutely fine so is a funeral we
recognize those are important life
events that need to go on with with
appropriate restrictions in place it's
the party part um that we've asked that
we've
put limits on right now and yes the 50
capacity in theaters etc
no tournaments continues
but the game playing is still
and they
making sure that that children and and
adults are able to continue with league
sports and games etc
continues as well in terms of the order
yeah this was something that has been in
the works for some time and local mhos
have been working with school districts
and it really is it serves two purposes
one it gives
the mhos in those school districts an
understanding of which schools might be
more at risk of having
closures because of outbreaks or where
there's transmission so we can focus
attention on those schools but
particularly it's it's to support the
school districts in that decision-making
about mandates as you know i've been
very clear that it is the employers who
are responsible for making those
decisions and in the way that our our
school system is set up it is the school
districts
who are the employers so it does make it
complicated that there's 60 different
school districts but the mhos in each of
the health authorities in each of the
areas are working with each school
district to understand risk and there's
a list of questions that school
districts need to wrestle with to
understand whether they need to put a
mandate in or not and i know delta has
made some decisions and
this was particularly to support in
interior health where there were a
number of school districts
that were in negotiations and
discussions with their staff and with
the mhos and we walked through
what that would look like and whether
the mhos would need to do it on an
individual basis and our
understanding
really was that if we had a provincial
standard
so an enabling order from me
that would allow it to be done on in a
consistent way
by each mho as needed
in partnership with their school
district so it really enables the school
district to
make it very clear that it is a legal
mandate that they are able to ask all
staff in that school district to report
their vaccination status and that is
a really important step in terms of
determining whether they
need to have a vaccine mandate in that
district or not
binder do you have a follow-up
i do um just with regards to the
vaccination card i know you said that
that order would also be extended and
i'm just wondering if you can talk a
little bit more about how long you think
that might be in place this year and
whether there are any places where
you've seen transmission or outbreaks
that where it may be expanded uh to
cover as well
yeah so we are still uh talking about
where the the vaccine card
is
some of those issues are still under
discussion as you know it's
put in place we put it in place in
august
up until january 31st hoping that we
would be in a place where it was no
longer needed but that's not the case
and it has been shown to be very
effective in in ensuring that we
mitigate all those risks in those
businesses
we do still are committed to to it being
those
businesses that are discretionary in a
sense where people
can have
alternative choices
i want to find that balance of
supporting businesses to stay open
supporting people to
be in an environment that is as safe as
possible and it has been very effective
in working on that so yes we are looking
at it extending it
to be able to support
businesses and support people and having
confidence in going to theaters and
restaurants and gyms
in the future but we have not yet made
the final decisions on whether it be
expanded or there's some places removed
and how long we'll do that for
and over to minister dicks
they really um uh shortly that more than
four million people in business
necessarily um download that certainly
that more than four million people in bc
have done download their bc vaccine card
and i want to thank them for their
support with this program which is
really
a central part of our response to the
covet 19 pandemic it has been enabling
it has allowed and allowed
restaurants for example and other cities
to stay open in challenging times and i
think that the bc vaccine card is not
just popular in the discussion or the
debate in bc it's popular where it
matters just as immunization is
important where it matters
and having more than four million people
with their vaccine card all those of
that group over 12 and having the levels
of vaccination we have
demonstrates the strong support of
british columbians for these measures
and i think they've been effective i
want to of course thank the business
community because they played a role in
it and others the non-profit sector and
making sure the vaccine card
is used effectively but i think
it's been overwhelmingly popular in bc
with good reason and i appreciate
everyone for being part of the program
with the
oh sorry what is the optimal amount of
time
in between a coven 19 infection
and getting a booster shot and would bc
consider changing the definition of
fully vaccinated to be three doses
rather than twos
yeah so there's a there's a bit of
back and forth on that but
in terms of
the booster shot what we are saying is
if you're at least six months from your
dose too as long as you're feeling
better from your infection then go ahead
and get the booster shot and really it
is about the future it's not about
obviously protecting you from whatever
is circulating rate now
but it is about giving you that
strongest longer lasting protection for
whatever comes next because something
is going to come next we're going to
have to be living with some version of a
sarsko v2
for the next
foreseeable future
and i expect and hope that it's going to
be less and less severe and that we'll
be able to manage it and part of that is
you know people getting booster doses to
help for longer lasting protection
particularly through next year
in terms of the vaccine card and what we
consider fully vaccinated
we are seeing that that two doses that
primary series right now is still giving
really strong protection for people
against severe illness and
hospitalization and i have no plans at
the moment for changing that one of the
things that that is important in
determining um you know what we do in
terms of the vaccine card and where
people are
able to access things is is you know the
the equity of availability of vaccine
and not everybody yet has reached that
point where they can have a booster dose
so it would not be fair to put in
restrictions when people are not able to
to meet the the criteria for them yet
and i still do believe
that we will not need a vaccine card
forever but it is an important tool
right now as we're in this this really
messy transition period with with
omicron and
trying to understand what comes next and
how we get out of this pandemic so
i don't expect to be adding a third dose
or a booster dose to the fully
vaccinated in terms of the things like
the vaccine card uh right now
andrea do you have a follow-up
yes thank you for that this is for a
colleague regarding the order that
medical health officers can compel
school staff to reveal their vaccination
status
in the past
some school districts were told that if
they were to implement a vaccine mandate
that they would be on their own for
paying for any sort of testing regime
and they wouldn't have the resources to
implement that so if a medical health
officer
did collect vaccination statuses and
they determined that a mandate was
required would the province provide any
additional resources to help implement
this
if you're you're misunderstanding the
intent of this order it's for the mhos
to to work on behalf of the the school
district to re require the school
district to collect this information
it's still the employer which is the
school district who determines whether
there's a vaccine mandate needed or not
this is an important piece of
information for the school district to
have and the order
makes it very clear that that is a legal
requirement for the school district
to be able to
get that information and to facilitate
making those decisions so it's not about
the mhos or me
requiring an employer to make a mandate
it's about facilitating the school
districts who are the employers
to make the best determination about
whether they need to have a vaccine
mandate in that school district or not
and it's an important piece of
information so
if the school district determines that
they want to have
a testing regime
then they would have to do that
themselves so it's not this order is not
around that um
and you know i think it really shows the
importance of the school district making
those decisions as the employer because
it is not the mho in public health or me
who is able to manage a vaccine mandate
program and it is
i know challenging that there's 60
different school districts but we are
trying to have a very consistent
approach to how we support school
districts in making those decisions
next question goes to lisa eusta city
news
dr henry with these new antivirals
coming and there was a comment teresa
tam made yesterday saying that
it would go to people who are most at
risk and the people who are most at risk
are often those who are unvaccinated and
that has a lot of people up in arms so
i'm wondering if you can talk about the
decision
the decisions that are made ethically
about who gets this and is it fair if
someone who's unvaccinated gets to stay
before someone who is vaccinated but
older perhaps with some immune
immunity issues somewhere if you can
talk about that
yeah these are all really really
challenging questions and
you know i think the other thing to put
it in perspective is right now there's
limited supplies and these ethical um
discussions become really really
important the other thing that is really
important that this is a combination pax
levid is a combination of two
antiviral medications one retonavir that
we've known for a long time it's one
that we use in anti-hiv treatment um the
other is
near material
near natural beer
i'm still learning how to say that one
um
which is one that helps block uh the the
reproducing of the virus in the in the
body and the uh retinovir basically
keeps it around and helps it work for
longer
but there are a lot of drug drug
interactions with these with this
combination so it's not an innocuous
medication so
that's another thing that we're
factoring into it and yes we have um you
know the federal government put together
a panel to look at some of these issues
and we've been looking at them again
with an ethical lens here in british
columbia and what we've put together is
what we call a heat map of you know
who's most at risk based on things like
underlying illness one or two conditions
vaccination status and age and it really
does the the risk is greatest in
older people no matter what age they are
over age 80 in particular but over age
70
and people who have immunocompromising
condition regardless of vaccination
stages and regardless of age so that
will be our first
focus is how do we
make sure so there's other limitations
that make it a challenge as well it has
to be started within five days of onset
of illness so you have to have a test to
make sure that it is the the correct
illness that you're testing that you're
treating um
and
so we're putting in place
measures to try and
get
a test to those people who are most at
risk and what we have in british
columbia through our clinically
extremely vulnerable group is we have
identified a group of people who are
most at risk regardless of vaccination
status so
we are working through all of these
issues about with this limited supply
particularly how do we ensure that those
people who are most at risk
are able to access testing and
the drug if needed in the shortest
period of time the other really
important consideration is
where we can use these medications to
help preserve
prevent people from needing hospital
care
in communities that where hospital care
is is not very accessible and we've had
some really
terrible outbreaks in some
first nations communities and remote
communities in the province so we are
working with the first nations health
authority and others to look at how we
can have rapid access in those
communities where we know there's a
higher risk of people needing care so
yes
these drugs have both malnopirovir and
vaxlavid have been tested in
the clinical trials were all in
unvaccinated people
and we know that the biggest benefit is
those most likely to end up in hospital
but there is a there is a
a whole spectrum of people and we're
focusing on how do we identify them um
earliest
please idea of a follow-up
i do minister dicks you spoke about um
hospitalizations and when you're listing
off all those numbers it certainly
sounds like we are at the brink and i'm
looking at island health just senator
list so i'm wondering if you can talk
about like how close we are to the edge
and let's say we get 200 more people in
hospital can
can we absorb that or are people moving
through fast enough i'm just wondering
how much more the system can absorb
before you need to open up say the field
hospital
oh i don't think the issue uh leaves as
a field hospital though we have that
capacity the issue is remember and just
today
we are we have uh
approximately
2234 vacant beds in our system
base and surge the issue is and what
makes this period different than past
period is the impact of sickness on our
staff and i went through those numbers
in detail and we're of course happy that
there are fewer days lost to sickness or
fewer people lost the sickness this week
impacted by sickness this week than last
week
and i would say apples to apples
comparison that i gave you earlier is
about 7 500 against
11 000 in those health authorities where
we had those statistics so that's a
significant increase in numbers so
that's the issue that we're facing yes
there are more people covered 19 in the
hospital but we're obviously making
changes in the system to ensure that
to reduce otherwise the need for acute
care beds and that's why
several weeks ago in our planning
we decided to postpone many non-urgent
scheduled surgeries it's a very
difficult decision to make and there's
certainly more capacity than that as i
told you
compared to week to week we we cancelled
about 25 2600 fewer schedule surgeries
than we did in the april and may period
of 2020. so uh the keep the bigger
challenges really
to the healthcare system are in smaller
communities and in services that are
separate and apart you can meet some of
these challenges with enormous
difficulty of course in hospital but you
can meet them but where you're more
challenges in things such as home
support services where it may be a small
number of people in more isolated rural
areas providing those services if a
number of them
test positive and have to
have to isolate with covet 19. so
the short answer is
i think
we're taking the steps now to ensure
that when british commons need health
services urgently they can get them
right now and we're ready then to
restore any services that have been
delayed we've done this before and we've
delivered before and we will again so um
i don't think we're
near that point yet but we want to in
detail let people know the situation
which is that there's a lot more
healthcare workers sick
than there are in the normal period in
this
period of relatively high sickness which
is uh january of any year
that that number declined in the last
week but it's still
significantly more than we would
normally see
and so we're having to take these steps
in order to protect essential services
and uh that's what we're doing and
that's we're going to continue to do and
twice a week we're going to update you
in detail on these although i know
sometimes the numbers are
are challenging to deal with you know
and when they come in that volume but
we're going to update you in detail to
give you a sense of where we are and
that's what we did today and that's what
we're going to continue to do
long-term care last week point grey
private hospital said that it had nine
people in its care home
with covet who tested positive focus six
staff and three residents but they said
it wasn't an outbreak because the cases
weren't related
so why aren't unrelated cases reported
as an outbreak if there are almost 10 of
them and you know shouldn't that
information still be made public for the
safety of potential visitors and
residents and if you could answer in
english and french please
and this is another one of those areas
where we have had to modify and adapt
our approaches as the virus has changed
so what we are seeing in outbreaks and
we've reported as you know i think we're
up to 50 some
right now both in acute care and in in
long-term care
but we've been working really closely
with the long-term care sector and my
colleagues who are on the grounds
making these decisions and really what
we're seeing is there's so much
illness out there
that we are seeing lots of healthcare
workers who work in care homes
test positive or have mild symptoms
and they are
connected to their risks in the
community we see a very similar thing um
particularly in
long-term care homes where people are
more mobile and and outside when they're
not there may not be transmission
between residents in the facility and we
have to balance this very mild illness
that we're seeing now because we have
such a highly vaccinated population in
our in our care homes both the
healthcare workers and the
and the residents so
there is the impact that outbreaks are
having is much
uh different than what we were seeing
even a few weeks ago with particularly
with with delta and you know why we
really started uh ramping up the booster
doses in long-term care homes so we are
revising our approach to outbreaks
because we're finding that the measures
that we put in place that have been very
very strict around covet outbreaks in
long-term care homes are causing more
harm than
omicron is at the moment and we need to
balance that with
a healthcare worker
being off ill with
relatively mild illness again too so we
are those are under transition and it
really is about looking at every
individual situation looking at where
transmission is happening how we can
manage to support people who are
positive and
try and dampen down and prevent
transmission within the facility without
putting in some of the more draconian
measures that have
really affected the quality of life for
residents and and our visitor strategy
is part of that making sure that that
one visitor per resident is really part
of the care team and and providing
support to residents regardless of how
the virus is being transmitted in in
care homes so on an individual home by
home basis uh those visitors right now
who are limited to the the one
designated visitor and essential
visitors
that they are aware of what is happening
in the home
and
we're trying to titrate the measures to
what we're seeing on the ground in terms
of these outbreaks right now as we've
seen the risk profile changing with
omicron over to minister dicks
challenge
the
[Music]
[Music]
see
staff declaring vaccination status do
all districts need to gather the
vaccination status of all staff now in
case a health officer asks for the
information or or do they have
only have to gather that information
when asked to provide it and mr dix if
you could explain the order about school
staff vaccination status in french that
would be very much appreciated
yeah
the answer is no this is an order that
it puts in place the framework for an
mho to use and the consistent
information that will be collected if
the mho in consultation with the school
district
makes the decision that
they want to understand this information
so not all school districts will are
required to do it it is
working in partnership with the mho
i know
in one school district today they'll be
issuing an order and the mho has been
working with that school district for
some time and
has been
it's really the genesis of this there
was uh pushback from the unions about
the concern that this was not a lawful
uh
ability to require that information so
this just makes it really really clear
and takes the pressure off if the mho
issues an order under this
provisions to the school district it is
it is legal and it must be complied with
and it will be on a district-by-district
basis in consultation with the mho
over to minister dix for french
[Music]
all right as health minister adrian
dicks answers in french there we'll wrap
up our coverage of today's
briefing with dr bonnie henry and the
health minister lots to unpack in this
one today
most excitedly i think for jim's and
their customers we'll talk about some of
the
restrictions that were lifted for them
and bring in keith baldry right now who
was listening as i was most restrictions
keith on bars and nightclubs and those
kinds of things are going to stay in
place
but it sounds like there is a lifeline
for gyms to operate with limitations
after today's briefing
yeah it's not going back to the way it
was before but gyms and fitness centers
are going to be allowed to open as of
thursday subject to new safety plans so
there have to be seven square meters
around each person that's 2.5 meters by
2.5 meters for social distancing
massacre required in most instances a
maximum of 25 people are present at any
one time depending on how large the
facility is so they are going to be able
to open but not
full-blown there's going to be subject
to safety plans and as you mentioned the
other orders which are really about
gatherings and events will remain in
place 50 capacity at indoor events and
bars and nightclubs will remain closed
uh
as of uh through mid-february i think
february 16th is the next time that
order could could expire so uh that
order could be extended again chris
depending on what we see with omicron in
terms of hospitalizations and case
numbers but the modeling last friday
projected that the case numbers would
continue to drop and they have been
dropping the positivity rate will
continue to drop the hospitalizations
will continue to increase but they're
supposed to just begin decreasing next
week if that does start happening then i
think you're going to see that health
order expire in mid february as is
currently the plan but if it keeps going
up all bets are off all right i i want
to get a little bit more into
hospitalization and sort of those
numbers that they got into today in a
moment but um let's first talk about the
details and it was a little bit
confusing um
that
are related to this mandate that school
staff declare vaccination status so dr
henry talked a little bit more about
what's in the provincial health order
that i guess basically empowers the
medical health officers in in each uh
region to be able to
put a mandate in that allows schools to
ask for that vaccination status so they
can figure out
what is the status of the teachers
yeah i won't be the medical health
officer doing all this work the school
districts have asked for this so they're
the employer they will get the
information themselves this is not going
into public health it's uh to be amassed
by the employer with the assistance of
the of the chief medical health officer
for that particular area so dr bonnier
is not the only medical health officer
in bc we have all sorts of them at
different health authorities they're
going to be working with districts to
collect this information
which could form the basis of a mandate
down the road you're not going to see a
mandate come in from public health but
the school district itself may impose a
mandate after it collects this
information uh she says it's gonna it's
gonna stand up to any legal challenges
but who knows we haven't seen a legal
challenge yet uh there are a number of
legal challenges across canada against
various vaccine mandates and we haven't
seen the outcome of any of them in court
yet but she feels confident based on the
advice they've got that this this
information will start being collected
and could form the basis of a vaccine
mandate down the road but we're early
days on this thing and there's still
some questions and to be answered on
this the fine print isn't readily
available quite yet
all right uh so
back to omicron and the impact on our
health system dr henry says we need to
get over this notion that omicron is
mild there are very high rates of
transmission
and still many people who get sick and
end up in hospital one in ten she said
today will have symptoms
that last 12 weeks or longer and and age
is still by far the number one risk
factor
yeah people over the age of 70 uh
statistically have the greater risk of
more severe outcome uh from kovalev 19
and omicron uh yeah there's notion that
omicron is mild it sure it's mild for
many people but it's not mild for a big
chunk of the population uh i know the
instances of two kids one age two one
age one uh who had to be rushed to
hospital tested positive for coveted 19
likely the omicron variant because they
had a temperature of 104
so that's a very dangerous situation so
omicron is mild for most people but not
for everyone that's why our
hospitalization numbers are just
exploding i think the number minister
dicks used today was 864 which is up
about 50 from yesterday uh which is
actually a smaller increase than what
we've been seeing the last few days so
that's that's uh
good news on that front luckily our icu
numbers have not been going up i think
he mentioned the figure 112 today that's
up uh
about a dozen from yesterday so again
keep an eye on the icu numbers so the
people in icu uh you know it's about a
50 50 split between vaccinated
unvaccinated so omicron is putting
people in the icu both in bc and also in
on places like ontario quebec
various american states omicron is still
very serious virus if and take all steps
to avoid getting it when you're over 70
and when you're unvaccinated and those
are major risk factors dr henry felt
compelled today to acknowledge
misinformation that's out there she's
obviously aware of what's being shared
on social media and use that to
encourage looking for credible sources
of information and to really encourage
childhood vaccination today
they are very worried very concerned
about the slow pace of growth when it
comes to the vaccination rates of kids
between the ages of five and eleven and
it's striking the difference in eight in
that age geographically is quite
striking i think uh the rate for five to
eleven year olds in the north is less
than uh 25 percent i believe but more
than 50 percent in metro vancouver
we're doing about 4 000 5 000 first
doses a day for the 5 to 11 year old
group
so some parents are sort of over
researching this on the internet and
drawing wrong conclusions based on
you know various websites so dr henry
yeah going out of her way today to say
no go to only credible
sources for information to determine why
you should get your kid vaccinated these
are very safe vaccines we've got real
word real world data of millions of kids
who've got the first dose and have had
no side effects or downside of getting
the first dose of vaccine and again when
i hear stories about a one-year-old and
a two-year-old having to go to hospital
even though they're not eligible for
vaccines right now that age group has
still not been
green lighted here it does mean a five
or six-year-old or a seven-year-old
could go to hospital as well and we are
seeing cases in the states of younger
kids going into hospital with omicron
and we saw
earlier on with delta variant so again
more reason to get your your child
vaccinated if they're eligible again
between the ages of 5 and 11. and if you
want more information talk to your
family doctor talk to your pediatrician
all of the details
including information about the safety
and effectiveness of the vaccines is
available on the bccdc website keith
much more coverage coming up this
afternoon thanks very much for your
analysis after today's briefing we'll be
back with much more this afternoon on bc
one